body rockin Biff Hutchinson has his
sights set on a world record
pogo flip Boing Boing Mike
Biff has just jumped into the record
books but how is the spring king going
so high a record-breaking pogo stick
can't just have an ordinary spring
because there's a limit to how much a
spring can be compressed once the spring
is compressed to its limit it becomes a
solid bar bifs pogo stick has a sealed
air cylinder inside of it when Biff
pushes down the bottom of the pogo stick
pushes a piston up into a chamber which
compresses the air inside it the high
pressure air inside the cylinder wants
to equalize with the outside air
pressure and it does that by pushing the
piston back out into the ground he
pushes Biff into the air
[Music]
the pogo stick is doing its job for sure
but there's also some biology in this
trick as he's being catapulted into the
air Biff is using his arm to maintain
his balance as well as to keep his body
straight this is important because he
wants to land on the pogo stick as
straight as possible to generate the
maximum force to spring himself back up
again
he also thrusts his arm up and this
helps get his body weight even higher
gaining those precious extra inches and
that record is pogoing going gone
[Music]